Is it too late to give a confidence monitor?
That's what we,
some of them might be on the way.
I clue. I Oh, okay. Well, very good.
Have you watched your, uh, sermons?
Have your, your little left, your little cushion?
I hadn't got to yet. No.
How much time to that are they gonna give you?
I'm not doing it tonight. Brad does it tonight. Who? Brad.
Air. So, well,
the doors were closed to remember the,
before they got the new units.
It took forever to get this place cooled off.
Now it like that, it went from,
it went from hypothermia.
There have been times I've been actually
took my hands off the camera for second, like, I couldn't,
he never moves, moves.
The one time I'm sitting there.
No, I'm sorry. Hi.
The one
everything up to the air.
I said I
can't,
it's here.
One or the other. Right? It's here.
You know Mike, Mike on production? Yeah.
Yeah, that's what I was wondering.
Or you stuff, or it's warm
and there's no way to, um, some kind of
goes down and then it comes back.
You have a,
I know it's a big space, but these
units, they used to be hours.
Remember hours.
You came in here and said, Hey, everybody
head over into the sanctuary.
Sometime everybody would be going, uh oh. It's be warm.
It's
when it gets to a certain temperature to,
oh, here it
doesn't, David.
Oh, really? I the door.
Thank you. That's why I have,
I mean, my hands are still cold.
Yeah.
Back row. People
get all your time about today.
Why?
Okay.
What's up?
Anybody not have handouts? Hello?
Anybody else not have handout?
Scary?
Is it working? No. No. I mean, I got, I've got it.
There's no, there's no, I think it's worse.
I told I don't do that. I sleep on my side,
but I think I'm gonna try it again.
Can't stand first. Then she rolls over and go.
It blows out her mouth on me. Roll over.
You don't, don't, you don't. That sucks.
I'm surprised it doesn't bleed over into that.
Maybe I do,
but you did.
I am used to not teach them without a microphone,
but I've been told some of You're hard of hearing on the,
so I'll use a microphone.
Anybody not get a hand up?
Very good. Well, we need to go ahead and get started
and, uh, we'll jump right into our
handout in just a few minutes.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna share some things
before we get to the handout.
Uh, my name is Aaron Ferguson.
I'm, uh, privileged to be able to serve
as one of your elders.
And can I just say before I get started, we are so grateful
for your participation in this semester of this class.
We were just talking about this last night at our meeting,
how encouraged we've been by your, uh, faithfulness
to attend this class.
And usually after fall break,
it goes down very quickly and you're still here.
So we're so thankful
and just grateful that you guys are taking the time
to invest in a really deep study
on the doctrines of scripture.
So thank you for that. Tonight is, is no less deep.
It's maybe even deeper.
And that's the topic of the providence of God.
And if I could pick one attribute of God,
that's my favorite, I don't know if that's fair to say.
Can you have a favorite of your attributes of God?
I'm not sure, but I do. And it's, that's the providence
of God for two reasons.
One, this doctrine is profound. There's no doubt.
But it's personal. It's profound, but it's personal.
You don't know what providence is.
The idea that God is sovereign over everything.
He's in control over every molecule, every minute,
every second, every nation, every event, every individual,
all the minute details.
And yet you and I have all this leeway to make decisions
and do the things we want to do in a day.
And somehow he makes it all work together
for his good purposes.
That is profound. Think about that for a second.
That will blow your mind.
But at the same time, it's personal.
And he has this big plan for the whole universe.
Who am I man? He's got a plan for you as well.
And he has plans down to the, the
smallest details in your life.
It's personal and you're a part of his plan.
That to me, that is, again,
profound and personal.
I love this. I love this doctrine.
Second reason I love this doctrine is
I get to teach it every day.
I, uh, if you don't know,
I teach at a little Christian school in Oklahoma City.
Uh, I've been there 32 years, my 32nd year.
And I get to teach history.
And I have the leeway at CHA to teach
history from a biblical perspective, which I was not taught.
And my guess is, you either were you,
but what does that mean to teach history
from a biblical perspective?
It means to teach it from a providential view.
What does that mean? God's in control.
He's in control of the whole story of history.
He's got a plan from the beginning to the very end
and everything in between.
And he's got a purpose for every nation, every event,
every individual I get to every day I get to,
to, to talk about that.
What was God's purpose for you? Fill in the blank.
That's what I get to do every day.
And it's, it brings history to life.
I was not taught that way. I was taught, you know,
about a bunch of dead people, uh, a long time ago,
memorized these dates and yada, yada yada.
And, uh, it was, it was boring.
How many of you, oh, I shouldn't ask.
How many of you were bored stiff in your history classes?
And it was because you weren't taught from a
providential perspective.
If you walk into a history class, knowing
everything we talk about has a purpose and a meaning,
and God fits it into this giant plan.
Okay, now I can get excited.
What was God's purpose for Alexander the Gray?
What's God's purpose for purpose? Abraham Lincoln?
What's God's purpose for me, that brings history to life.
And that's why I love this.
I, uh, was 23 when I came to CHA, right outta college.
Never even heard the word providence.
I grew up in a, in the church.
I grew up in a Christian family.
No one ever taught the doctrine of providence
on a public school product.
I didn't hear providence in public schools.
So I'm 23, I come to CHA, they put me in a class
with a video from RC sprawl.
Mm-hmm. Called the Providence of God.
And that was my introduction to this doctrine.
And I was like, how come I've never heard this before?
Mind blowing profound and personal.
And then I came to realize,
after studying all these years,
our forefathers were very familiar with this doctrine.
They used the word providence almost
in everything they said.
And so it's very fun for me to point out the use
of providence in history.
It's unbelievable. They called it the hidden hand, the hand
of God, the invisible hand providence.
Unbelievable. So our forefathers been
to this doctrine, thank you.
And it's come to life for me,
and I can't wait to, to get to share some of it with you.
I'm gonna start, before we get to our,
before we get to our handout, I'm gonna start
with my favorite providential passage.
And so if you have your bibles,
I'm gonna ask you to open your Bibles.
What Bible study? Yes.
I'm gonna ask you to open your Bibles. Isaiah chapter 46.
It's my favorite providential passage.
Isaiah 46.
If you have not underline, lined this verse, these passages,
starred these passages, highlighted these passages.
I would encourage you to do this, Isaiah 46
verses nine through 11.
And just in case you didn't bring your Bible,
or if you're like me, you can't read
your Bible anymore without glasses, uh,
I put it on the screen for us.
This is from the New American standard,
nothing against the ESB, which we use here at church.
I, I'm a big fan of the NASB.
And so here is Isaiah 46, my favorite
providential passage.
Alright, here we go.
Remember the former things long past out,
remember the former things long pass?
What do I do for a living? I love this verse already.
I teach history, right?
Remember the things from former, uh, former things,
long pass for I am God
and there is no other.
Wait a minute. Why should we remember the things from the
past, Brian?
God? And there is no other.
In other words, we remember things from the past
to remind us of what God has done.
Again, I love history. I am God.
And there is no one like me declaring the end from the
beginning and from ancient times, things which have not
been done.
I'm gonna keep going here in just a minute,
but let that sink in just for a minute.
God declares the end from the beginning
and from ancient times, things which have not been done.
Why is that profound?
That is profound. Yes. Why? He's not bound by time.
He's not bound by time he knows
what's gonna happen in the end.
And by the way, he knows what's gonna happen in the
end while he's standing.
Where At the beginning.
At the beginning, I already know
what the story is all about.
'cause I wrote it. Alright?
He, he's declaring the end from the beginning.
He knows it all from ancient times,
things which haven't even been done.
That is, that's profound. Again, profound.
But hold on, it's personal. Let's keep going.
My purpose will be established
and I will accomplish all my good pleasure
calling a bird of prey from the east
and the man of purpose from a far country.
Truly, I have spoken. And truly I will bring it to pass.
I have planned it. Surely I will do it.
Do the events in your life
and the events of the world around us happen by accident?
No. How do we know that from this verse?
How do we know that? What words? Gimme a word.
I've planned it. He planned it. God has a plan. I'll do it.
I'll do it. I'll accomplish, I'm gonna accomplish my plan.
Whatever He's already,
he already knows the plan he's gonna accomplish.
He's gonna work it out
my purposes.
Nothing happens by accident.
We're not victims of fate or chance or circumstance.
He's got a purpose. And by the way,
his purposes are good.
Good. I'm gonna accomplish my pleasure, my purposes.
And by the way, they're good. Mm-hmm. Okay.
We could spend the rest
of the night on this passage right here.
This is phenomenal, is profound,
but it's personal.
And that is the providence of God.
Uh, we'll get into the pray from the e, the, the bird
of pray from the East and the man of purpose and all that.
What in the world does that mean?
We'll get into that in the, in the study.
But let's start with a word of prayer.
Now that we've kind of set the stage here for our study.
Lord, we're grateful for tonight.
I'm grateful for these friends who have taken time
to be here and to study and to learn.
But it is much more than just learning about you.
Our head can only, you know,
our head can only keep so much knowledge.
It's not about just learning about you.
It's about falling in love with you
and learning to experience you.
And so tonight, I pray that it's not just the, the facts
of the doctrine of providence,
but that you would click in our hearts
and our minds to, to trust you more
because of what we learn in this doctrine tonight.
So thank you God. I pray you'll bless
this time in Jesus' name.
Amen. Alright,
the providence of God.
I've given you a handout.
I'm gonna follow the handout as best I can here.
Uh, but the handout is actually broken down into
five sections.
We're gonna talk about where,
what is providence, where did it come from?
And the, uh, systematic theology root
and breaks providence into three sections, preservation,
concurrence, and government.
And then we're gonna apply it at the end.
What are some applicant, how do we walk away from this
study and apply this?
This is kind of how this is all broken down.
So let's jump right in.
Is providence, even in the Bible, in the,
find the word providence in the Bible, uh,
you will not find the word providence in the Bible.
We made this word up to summarize
the concept of God working all things for good.
And so you, if you did a really quick search for providence,
you're not gonna find, it's kinda like the word trinity.
I wrote in the notes. It's kind of like the word trinity.
It's not in the Bible, but the concept is, right?
So, okay, we made this word up. And so, alright, what is it?
It's from a Latin, two Latin words put together pro
and theo, you should recognize Theo, we, we,
we say video, right?
Pro means before. And the day of video means to see.
So put those two together, pro eo
to see something before it happens.
Uh, we might say foresight.
We see before it happens, uh, very in a,
in a very small degree, we see
that there's a hundred percent chance of rain on Friday.
So I should wear my rain jacket
or I should carry my umbrella.
That's foresight. Is
that what's being described by providence?
God can see that it's gonna rain.
Uh, no, there's much more to it than that.
But that's what probe AEO means.
And so, Webster, I love to go to Webster's 1828 dictionary.
Elders give me a hard time about this.
'cause I, I love this dictionary. First American dictionary.
And Noah Webster was a Christian.
He writes the dictionary,
the definitions from a biblical worldview.
It's what?
And he gives, uh, places in scripture find his definitions.
I mean, okay, so why would you not use this dictionary?
And, uh, they have an app. Mm-hmm.
Uh, the 1820 eight's about that big.
But you can, you have an app.
You just, anyway, I use it every day in my,
my just my quiet time run across a word.
What does that mean? Anyway, so Webster's 1828,
that's why I'm using this.
The act of providing
or preparing for future use, providing advance
is a good definition of providence.
Timely care. And remember foresight eo,
he says active foresight.
That's different than just, I can see
that it's gonna rain on Friday.
Active foresight means, uh,
God doesn't just know what's gonna happen.
He can bring it about the way he wants it to happen
to meet his good pleasure.
That's active foresight. You and I can't do that.
Timely care, active foresight, accompanied
with the procurement that the gathering of what is necessary
for future use or with suitable preparation, okay?
So provide an advance, even has a definition in theology.
The care and superintendents, which
God exercises over his creatures.
And here's what I love about, uh, Noah Webster.
He adds this little comment.
He that acknowledges a creation
and denies a providence,
involves himself in a contradiction.
The same power which caused a thing to exist.
God is necessary to continue its existence.
What are you gonna find? A dictionary that talks like that.
That's why you use the 1828.
But what he's saying is God has to continue to be there
for us to continue to exist.
Okay? So that's Webster's definition of providence.
How does brodo and systematic theology define this?
God is, uh, continually involved
with all created things in such a way.
Note the three sections.
These are the three sections we're gonna break up this,
uh, topic into.
He keeps them existing
and maintaining the properties with which he created them.
So he keeps, he cooperates with created things
and every action directing their properties to cause them
to act as they do.
So he keeps, he cooperates
and then he directs, he directs them to fulfill
his purposes.
So what I've done in your notes here is we're gonna break
this into, he keeps preservation.
He cooperates, concurrence,
he directs government.
So that's the next three sections here. Alright?
So let's dive into preservation.
Uh, these are big words,
but don't be scared of these words that the, uh, you know,
the theologians have to use these big terms.
But don't, don't be scared of these
what is meant by preservation.
Again, let's go back to Webster, the act of preserving
or keeping preservation preserved to keep.
And Gruden says the same thing.
God keeps all created things existing,
maintaining the properties with which he created them.
So we're talking about God keeping, sustaining
that which he has created.
So where do we observe this in scripture?
I've listed some verses there.
Let me put 'em on the screen for you.
We won't take time to look these up.
But Nehemiah says, you are the Lord.
You alone, you have made the heavens
and the earth and all that is in them.
And you preserve them all. You keep them all.
You keep all of creation.
Acts 17, Paul says, for in him, we live and move and exist.
Remember Noah Webster, we can't exist unless God exists.
Okay? So in him, we exist, Colossians chapter one,
he is before all things.
And in him, all things hold together in holding,
keeping present.
And then in Hebrews chapter one, he upholds all things
by the word of his power.
So you keep seeing this, keep, preserve, uphold.
That is the doctrine of preservation.
That's a part of providence. Okay?
So, uh, preservation, very simple.
God has to continue to sustain what he's created.
Otherwise, we would all cease to exist. It's pretty simple.
This is much more profound concurrence.
Here's your big word for the day, concurrence.
But you need to add this to your vocabulary
because this is phenomenal.
What in the world is concurrence?
Again, let's go back to Wester.
It's a combination of events.
He says circumstances or events,
or excuse me, agents or events.
When, when two or more things come together,
like this room right here where we have 30 people,
40 people in here, you all were going your various
directions today.
But at six 15, we all came together in this room.
Concurrence took place for all of us to sit in this class.
However, there's much more to it than that.
Concurrence. Two or more things working together.
Here's how Grham says it.
God cooperates with created things in every action,
directing their distinctive properties to cause keyword,
cause them to act as they do cause God causes.
Okay? But we also cause things.
So there's, you are causing things
and God is causing things.
We're both causing things. That's concurrence.
They're both a combination of
cau causation that's happening here.
So, okay, God is the primary cause, Perdu says,
and his creatures that's us, are the secondary cause
You make decisions all day long,
but God somehow causes your decisions to align
with his purposes.
That again, profound. How does he do that?
He's got to be sovereign in control
of everything to do that.
That's why he's gone. And we're not,
both agents work simultaneously.
Okay? So where do we see examples
of concurrence in scripture?
This is where it really gets spun.
Uh, you can talk about these things,
but let's find 'em in the Bible.
How, how do we see these things in the Bible?
And, uh, grham lists five ways
that we see concurrence in scripture creation,
the animals random
or chance events, nations and individuals.
I'd like to kind of take these one by one
and I want to ask you for some examples.
Here's where you're gonna get to participate.
Where do we see concurrence in scripture creation?
So let's just think creation here for a minute.
I wrote there for you.
Snow, rain, lightning, wind, grass, flowers.
You get creation things he's created.
Uh, Matthew five, your father in heaven causes the son
to rise on the evil in the good causes.
He created the son to rise and, and set on its own,
but he's also causing it to rise
and set on its own concurrence.
He also sends rain on the righteous in the unrighteous.
But wait, isn't there this process of evaporation
and, and the water cycle.
I mean, he made it that way, yes,
but he can say, Hey, go rain over there.
Right? He sends rain.
So concurrence, where do we see an example in scripture?
I'm sure you may be thinking about it already,
where God exhibits this in creation.
His, uh, sovereignty over creation.
This happens all over the Bible.
If you're paying attention to scripture,
this happens all the time.
The flood. Okay, very good. Made the sun stand still.
He made the sun stand still during a battle.
So win the battle, the big fish. Swallow the big fish.
Yeah, fish. Fish eat things that are in front of them.
Fish with money in mouth.
But God said, Hey fish, go over there and swallow that guy.
Okay, so there's concurrence. I'm sorry, go ahead. David.
Fish with money in the mouth. Yeah, with money.
Jesus said, uh, hey, it's starting to pay our taxes.
Would you go down and catch a fish?
My taxes are gonna be in his mouth.
And so the disciples go down and get the fish.
Sure enough, there's a coin in there for his taxes.
Wouldn't that be nice? Uh, that's, I don't know.
I can't say that's cheating because he's the son of God.
That doesn't seem fair. You know,
he walked on water, he walks on water.
What does he do to the storm? It's, it's storming.
And he says, cease be still.
H Okay, so we see this all in scripture.
Uh, creation just continues to, to, to, to go.
But he also can't control it.
Concurrence, one
of my favorites is the tree that he withers.
You know what I'm talking about? Cursed.
You're, there's nothing to eat on this tree.
What good are you? And he curses the tree and it die.
I mean, uh, why is that my, one of my favorites?
There's a lot to that story, but, okay, you get the idea.
Animals, uh, look at the birds of the air.
They don't sow or reap or gathering at the barns,
and yet your heavenly father feeds them.
Remember, this is personal. We got birds everywhere,
but God is in the details.
Hey birds, there's, uh,
somebody spilled a bunch of stuff over here.
Why don't you eat it? Concurrence. Okay?
So this is, this is amazing.
Where do you see God using animals?
We said the big fish. Daniel and the lions.
Daniel and the lions den.
Lions heat people, especially when they're hungry.
BA's hungry BA's donkeys speaking through the donkey.
Yeah, Elijah and MCC crows. The crows bringing Elijah food.
The bears and the bears, yeah. Sick them.
I mean, yeah, there's some amazing stories about animals
and how God orchestrates these animals.
Uh, it's really fascinating when you think about it.
He has control over his creation
and he's using animals, just do animal things.
But he is able to, to use them to do his good bid.
What, what about the flood?
Uh, animals just showed up at the a.
Wait a minute, what, why twos, how's he doing that?
And just enough to build the arc in the space they have.
I mean, okay, this is profound, but this is amazing.
Uh, random or chance events.
You know, God is in control of random or chance events.
You need to be really careful.
I've been careful when I learned this at age 23.
One of the things RC Spro drilled into my brain was,
don't use the word luck.
That was lucky, man.
I, I'm having a string of bad luck, or that was an accident
or a coincidence.
Uh, you gotta eliminate those things from your, now I know
what we mean by that.
Nobody, you know, we,
we don't really mean a whole lot by that.
But sometimes some people do.
They believe in luck or whatever happen stands.
Uh, if you believe that God is in control of all things
and has a purpose for everything,
there's no no such thing as luck.
There's no such thing as an accident.
Ooh, we just had an accident. We know what that means.
We didn't mean to do that. It was unplanned,
unplanned from our end.
It was an accident from his end.
There's no accident that, okay, this,
this will blow your mind.
Right? This is profound.
Now, what's the most random thing we could do?
Is take a paradise, roll 'em across the floor,
and then trust whatever the dice says
to be a decision to be made.
And let's just say we have a big decision.
Should we change the next apostle?
Choose the next apostle.
The disciples have Juda has killed himself.
We gotta replace him. How are we gonna cheat?
We put some guys up here, the boat,
and they picked Mattias.
Wait, how? What? Yeah. Proverbs says, the lot is cast.
We don't necessarily use lots,
but in Old Testament they did.
We use dice. You can cast the dice,
but every decision's from the Lord.
What? There's no such thing as luck.
That's crazy. Remember when, uh, Joshua
and the Israelites attacks Jericho
and they weren't supposed to take anything from Jericho.
Haken take something from Jericho
and they lose the next battle.
And Josh was like, what in the world's going on here?
Who did it? Nobody would say anything. So what did they do?
They brought out the lots.
Not that tribe next, not that tribe next.
And they got all the way down to eighth.
What that is, that's God's providence. This is crazy.
How did Saul become king? They chose the different tribes.
Came all the way down to King. Saul. Jonah.
Remember Jonah, who's causing this storm?
Let's cast lots and find out. Oh, it's Jonah.
He says, yeah, throw me overboard.
Okay, so this, this is, this is crazy.
Yeah, the dice are cast
and yet every decision is from the Lord.
By the way, these aren't just fun Bible stories.
Uh, Christopher Columbus
and his journals, they had a big storm
Who's causing this storm?
This is in the 14 hundreds. Guess what they did?
It came down to him. He said, no, something's wrong here.
We'll do this tomorrow. Next day came down
to him causing the storm.
We do this tomorrow. Three times came down to him.
What are the chances? What are the odds of that one
of us needs to go to Vegas, right?
Uh, no.
God is in control even of these random events.
There's no such thing as random.
I, uh, coached volleyball for many years.
Some of you heard this story.
And, uh, this other coach would always come up
before the game and say, good luck.
I mean, good providence. You're not.
'cause I know y'all don't believe in luck around here.
And he was always giving me a hard time,
which I, that's fine.
'cause we always beat his team. Uh,
but anyway, I he's right.
We don't believe in luck. I don't believe in luck.
God's in control even of random and chance events, nations.
He's got control of nations.
I mean, we're talking millions of people. You bet he is.
He made from one man every nation
to live on the earth and watch this.
He determined their time. When will they rise?
When will they fall? Where are the Romans today?
Thousand years. And when they're gone.
Alright, where are the Greeks today? Right?
Uh, he determines their times.
And by the way, their boundaries, Persians,
you can go all this far.
And then they invaded, uh, Europe three times.
And they, they did not succeed. God said, this is it.
No, no, past this record. God's in control of nations.
Even says the king's heart is in my hand.
I can turn it like rivers of water.
So nations, no big deal.
And uh, Daniel, he says, nations are like a drop
of buck in a bucket, drop of water in a bucket.
No problem has God in control of the United States.
He's in control of all nations.
Uh, one day people are gonna say, man,
the United States, where is it?
Right? He, when he's done with us, he's in control.
He determines the time.
So yes, uh, he is sovereign over these things.
This is concurrence. What about individuals?
Now we're getting personal man may plan his way,
but the Lord directs his steps.
How is that an example of concurrence? Jesus.
Judas, we'll get to Ju Yeah, very good Judas.
We'll get to Judas in just a second from that verse.
How do you see concurrence? It's a combination.
He's not saying don't plan, but we do make a plan.
We do plan. But ultimately he
steers, he steers how that happens.
We have a, we've been keeping up with all the football games
that are being changed on Friday
because the weather's coming in,
man may plan his way.
God brings the rain.
And so now we've gotta change our plans. Concurrence.
We plan all day long,
but God is the one who orchestrates your steps.
Alright, concurrence, this is, uh, this is phenomenal.
Now, question.
And you might be thinking, if God's in control
of everything, including me, are my choices real?
Do my choices really matter?
And the answer to that is obviously yes.
You go jump off a tall building,
you're gonna find out your choices matter.
Okay? You run out of the highway
and slap your choices matter.
So now, wait a minute. My choices matter.
My choices have consequences.
Yes, but God's still in control
and he uses my choices, all of our choices to weave
and work his purposes.
That is that again, that's profound.
Our choices do matter.
Now, a question we may al also also get
is do we have free will?
Uh, do we, do we really have free will if God is in control?
Good question. Uh,
free should be in quotation marks there.
'cause we really, we are free. You get to make choices.
You made a thousand choices today,
but your will is really not free.
You can't determine to do anything outside
of God's control, right?
Uh, there's a, there's a universe
and you can't act outside of that universe.
You, you, you're bound by his sovereignty.
So you're really not free and you're a sinner at heart.
You're, the Bible tells us
that we are enslaved before Christ.
We are enslaved to sin.
You're really, your will is not free.
It's bound by your simple nature.
So free really should be in quotation mark there.
But yes, you and I of any
of the creatures God has created are the most free,
given the most freedom to do
whatever we want to do in a day.
Nobody told you what to do today.
Well, maybe your boss, you have to go to work, right?
Or your spouse. You gotta do these errands.
Somebody may have told you what to do today,
but most of us get to decide what to do in a day.
You have free will,
but it's not free in the sense that I can do anything I want
outside of God's control.
That that's not, you don't have that type of freedom.
Here's how RC Spro says it in
that video I was telling you about earlier.
If God's not in control of all things,
then he's not sovereign.
He's not sovereign, then he's not God.
And if our free will can trump divine providence,
then who's ultimately God, we are,
that conclusion is unacceptable to anyone
with a biblical worldview.
In other words, if, if our will, if God doesn't know,
God's sitting up there going, what's he gonna do today?
You're really in charge and not him.
That's what's gonna say divine providence does not
destroy our freedom.
RC says, rather divine providence takes
our freedom into account.
And the infinite wisdom of God sets our course
to fulfill his will.
Anybody understand that? No, but we know it's true.
Okay, so the million dollar question then, what about evil?
What about evil? Uh, good question.
This is, uh, the million dollar question.
You know, the atheist always likes to throw out Christians.
Uh, there's so much evil in the world.
How can God be in control?
Okay, keep in mind we have dual agents here.
God's a cause and a man's a cause.
And God is not responsible for evil.
The Bible says he he can't do anything that's,
uh, not good.
Good is who he is, but man is responsible for evil.
And, uh, God, though we know from scripture allows
or ordains evil to occur, but he still sovereign over it.
Now, this is, this is really tough
because man can do some wicked things
and yet God still comes in sovereign over it.
That's, that's amazing.
So he's able to use evil for his good purposes.
That you just take those three right there
and think on those three for a little bit.
And, and that is some, that's some rich stuff right there.
But we know scripturally that this is true.
Uh, Joseph is a perfect example.
That's probably my favorite story when
it comes to Providence.
Uh, his brothers just happened
to sell into Egypt, into slavery.
He just happened to end up in Potiphar's house whose
wife just happened to come on to him.
So he just happened to flee.
So he just happened to get arrested
and just happened to get thrown into prison.
And he just happened to run into two guys working
for Pharaoh and,
and just happened to interpret their dreams.
And then he ends up, just happened to interpret
Pharaoh's dreams and just happened
to save the whole world from a family.
That's a whole lot of bad things that just, he had a lot
of bad luck there, didn't he?
But we know at the end of Genesis,
he tells his brothers what you meant for evil against me.
God meant for good. These guys are
responsible for the things they did.
And Nick, God was able to use that and turn into good.
That, that's just unbelievable. Pharaoh was evil.
He did evil things to the Israelites.
And God told Moses to tell Pharaoh, for this reason,
I've allowed you to remain.
I allowed evil to remain,
to show you my power.
I'm gonna bring down Egypt
to proclaim my name through all the earth.
Everybody's gonna know my name
because of you, Pharaoh, so evil.
You can exist. But God is in control.
Joe, the Lord gave the Lord took away everything from Joe,
blessed it be the name of the Lord.
He says through all this Job 1 22, he did not sin
and did not blame God.
Evil men do evil things, but he doesn't blame God.
God does not do evil.
Uh, so we're accountable for our decisions.
Evil is, uh, something we're responsible
of, responsible for.
Luke 22, the son of man will go as it has been determined,
but woe to the man by whom he is betrayed.
Somebody point out the concurrence there.
If it wasn't for Judas, Jesus would possibly
Die. If
it wasn't for Judas, you wouldn't have been arrested
and you wouldn't end up dying on the cross.
She said, good. What's the concurrence though?
It concurrence is it was determined.
It was determined Who determined it. God did.
But woe to the man who betrays him.
In other words, Judas is responsible for his own decisions.
This is okay, this is concurrence. This is evil.
How God uses evil.
Ran across a poem long time ago, just is phenomenal
by a pastor, a theologian named Arthur Pearson.
And, uh, it's on the left hand margin there.
I know it's very small. Uh, so I put it on the screen.
Listen to these words. This is, this is excellent.
Back of all that foes had plotted behind all
that foes had plotted back of all that saints have planned
back of schemes by men
or demons, moves a higher hidden hand.
In other words, behind all these things, God is working.
Warp and woo,
are heavens making time out warping what in the world.
This is, uh, when somebody is knitting warping woo warping,
woo, warping woo.
When you make a pattern warping, woo, that's a, those are,
that's a terminology that's being used here.
God is weaving, making something from our
events, from our lives.
Warping move for heaven's making.
He's making a pattern out of us.
All the pattern good and wise, though on earth,
side off perplexing.
We don't understand clear and right to heavenly eyes.
All Earth's agents act with freedom. We have free will.
Choosing whether love or hate faith in God and
or bold defiance, none are shackled slaves of faith.
Nobody's telling you what to do.
Yet the hand that guides is hidden, moving secret
and unseen firmly guiding life's great drama.
Every act and shifting seen even human wrath,
unknowing serves that all controlling will man proposes
God disposes all things his designed
fulfill to that goal.
Of all the ages, all of his history's windings tend,
they all end up in the same place.
And despite all foes
or factions, God proves victor in the end, mysteries,
which hurt and baffle past our power to understand,
we just don't get it in the end.
Our turn to blessing by that sovereign hidden hand
that is the doctrine of providence, as best
as I could put it in a poem that, that's amazing.
Arthur Pearson. Well done.
Alright, let's wrap up with the last section here,
the government of Providence.
What is meant by the government of Providence?
Uh, here's what grew them says here,
God has a purpose in all that he does.
And he providentially, governs
or directs all things to accomplish his purposes.
We've kind of been saying that already with concurrence,
but uh, back to Isaiah, my purpose
and my pleasure, I will accomplish.
He's, he's governing
and directing everything to meet his goodwill.
That's, that's the governance of providence.
Alright, but doesn't providence encourage my laziness?
If God's in control, why do I need to do anything? Right?
So my students say, I didn't study last night
because God's in control
and he's gonna help me do well on my test.
Good luck with that. I shouldn't say good luck.
Good providence with that.
Uh, Gruden gives the example of a farmer.
The farmer says, God, give me a crop.
But he doesn't do any work. It's not gonna happen. So, okay.
And by the way, laziness is frowned
upon in scripture, right?
We're we're supposed to be hard workers.
Diligent laziness is a sin.
He does not work, shall not heeds.
So, okay, Providence does not
encourage laziness.
But what we can be assured of is when we work hard
and do things under the Lord, we also can be rest assured
that he's working to bless our efforts as we go.
How does Providence intersect with prayer?
And this is a good question as well.
Uh, if God's in control and he knows all things
and he's working all things, why do I need to pray?
Okay? That's what the question is here.
God is ordained prayer, uh, for says to be a means
to bring about results in the world.
He knows our needs Before we ask Matthew six,
your father knows what you need before you ask him.
If he knows what I need, why should I pray and ask him?
Well, keep reading scripture.
We have not because we asked for him.
He knows what you need, but you didn't ask for it.
Oh, until now you've asked for nothing and ask
and you shall receive.
Oh, okay. So that's why we pray it's much more than that.
But, uh, we'll get to that in just a minute.
Paul says, pray without ceasing.
Okay, but wait, God's in control. He knows everything.
He's working everything. Why do I need to pray?
And Paul says, pray without ceasing.
Uh, there's a, what's interesting here is
why, why do we need to pray?
One of the one
of the misconceptions about prayer is we think that we're
talking God into doing something.
God, you know, would you do this for me?
Uh, prayer is not for him. This is our sprawl here.
Prayer's not for his good, but for for yours.
Prayer reminds us, uh, excuse John.
Uh, prayer's not so much for him.
He, he already knows what he's gonna do.
But it's to remind us where our source is,
where our health comes from.
We are to pray to constantly keep our eyes on him.
It's not, it's
because he goes, oh, I didn't know you needed
that until you pray.
He also loves and he loves it. He loves for us to talk.
It's a conversation with him. Absolutely. So, okay.
That's how providence and prayer work together.
Let me wrap up and then I'm gonna hand this over
to Brad here in just a second.
What are some ways we can apply this?
Uh, I put some things in there. This is not from groom.
These are things that, uh,
I've read in other books on Providence.
But let's apply this to our lives. Providence is personal.
Uh, if God has a big grand story
for everything, then you're a part of that story.
He has a purpose for you and for me.
And he's working all these things out in your
life as part of that story.
Even the smallest details. Uh, it's personal.
I told you at the very beginning.
Providence is profound and personal at the same time.
Providence is punchable. We don't like this.
We want God to work on our timetable,
but he's always on time.
If you think about it from his
perspective, he's always on time.
He's not on our time, but he's always on time.
He's punctual. You can always count on him to do,
uh, what he says he's gonna do on time.
Uh, providence is probably my favorite,
produces a peace of mind.
I don't have to fear or fret or worry
or dread circumstances
because I know he's in control
and he's working all things for my good, good.
You all know this. So when I think about those things,
it gives me a piece of mind.
Others may fear all kinds of things.
You and I don't have to because of providence.
It also encourages our faith.
I know God's gonna come through 'cause I know he's working.
He's sovereign. He will do it. He said he would.
It also breeds humility. I'm not in control. What?
I'm not in control and neither are you.
Somebody else is in control that that humbles me.
So the Bible says, we don't say I'm gonna do this and such.
We say, what do we say?
If the Lord wills, I'll do this and such, right?
I'm not in control of God.
If you would let me today, I would love to,
to do X, Y, and Z.
It breeds humility in us
and it encourages patience and suffering.
You're going through something hard, difficult,
painful, and we all have been there.
We can be patient because we know God is working these
things out for our good.
And so I don't have to, you know, I don't have to, uh,
to get angry at God.
I don't have to demand
that he tell me why things are happening.
I can just be patient because I know he's
working all these things out.
Providence is very application, uh,
applicable to our lives.
I'll finish with, this is my summary of the doctrine.
God cooperates with his creation to accomplish his will
and good purposes.
Can we fully understand this doctrine? Absolutely not.
It's profound. It's beyond our minds.
But can we trust that it's true? Absolutely.
It's in his word. We know it's true.
Proverbs tells us, trust the Lord with all your heart
and lean not on your own understanding.
My last, uh, slide here and I'll hand this over to Brad.
Uh, my challenge to you tonight when you go to bed tonight
is to reflect on God's progress in your life.
Even today, God's been at work.
What's he been up to today? You've been so busy.
I've been so busy running and doing
and living on no margin at all.
But when you lay down at night, reflect on your day.
What has God been up to today?
What are the little evidences of Providence?
One of my favorite books on
Providence, the mystery of Providence.
John Flail, uh, he
who believes in providence will have providences
to note you.
If you're mindful of providence,
you'll always see it everywhere.
That was providential. That was providential.
We say that was a God thing, but guess what?
Everything's a God thing. But do you have evidences
in your life today when you lay down at night?
God, show me what you did today.
I wasn't even paying attention. Show me what you did today.
Years ago, uh, we were poor.
I was working at CHA, Annie was home with four kids.
Our air conditioner went out
and we were told $3,000 to fix it.
We didn't have that kind of money.
And so we were like, what are we gonna do?
We didn't tell anybody. This not one person, two people,
one a friend and another family member sensed that
they needed to bless us somehow.
We didn't tell 'em a thing.
They both sent us a check for $1,500.
That was lucky.
So here's my second challenge.
Providence has happened all the time around you.
He's always at work. Where is he?
You have Providence as to know you do have some today.
You might have some this week,
you might have some this year.
Do you celebrate God's providence in your life?
Do you market somehow?
We put a big sign next to our thermostat. God is cool.
So every time I walked down the hall, God is cool.
I remember that story. God's at work.
What will you do when you lay your head down tonight?
And are you marking the providences in your life?
It's an amazing, amazing doctrine.
It's not just to know more about God, it's to experience him
fall more in love with him.
So thank you Brad.
Uh, Sylvester is gonna come and lead us in some discussion.
Thank
You. You glad?
Yes.
That we have elders like Aaron
and some of these guys sitting in the background
who can not only lead and care
and protect, teach Thank
you masterclass.
And we've had them every year.
So back to levels.
Providences to note.
Would anybody like to share their own providence
to note a time
or an experience of
where you saw God's providence happen in your life?
Floor is open.
How much time do we have? Not much.
Brad, do you want a long story or a short story?
I've got nine minutes. Okay.
Um, so this is a, an evidence
of God's providence in my life, in the life
of his providence.
But, um, 15 years ago,
I found myself at a year of training in St.
Louis. That was my last choice of places to go
to study what I do.
And I didn't want to be there.
And I'll say that I enjoyed
it while I was there, but I didn't wanna go.
Halfway through the year
was when the giant earthquake happened in Haiti.
And uh, and I felt this just urging in my heart,
God's urging my heart to go and serve there.
So I followed that.
There's the long version is how he opened all those doors.
But I found myself there
and there was a young boy
who was about 12 years old at the time,
who had his leg crushed.
And the word I received was a
don't need to take this kid's leg.
We're gonna try and save it. Okay?
So we took care of him, had a bunch of other kids
and a lot of stories.
And, um, two weeks went by. I went back to St.
Louis the day after I got back, went to work the next day.
And uh, they said, Hey,
TR there's a kid coming from the hospital.
You were in Haiti to have his leg reconstructed here.
I said, oh, that's a lot.
And so the Lord had constructed for him to come to to St.
Louis to have that procedure done.
And so he stayed there and had that was successful.
Um, and in the process, learning English was cared for
by a family who took care of him, cared for his needs,
physically, spiritually, all the things.
Um, fast forward 15 years,
that same young man is now a fourth year medical student
who is here in Oklahoma City today rotating
as a medical student
for orthopedic surgery resident at ou.
So I mean, that's looking back on the Walgreens,
there's a hundred evidences
of God's providence all through that.
Anybody else? You can't make that up. You can't.
Yes. I used to be a surveyor back in the day.
Worked international mostly.
Uh, I was about 2122 on my first hit in Africa.
Uh, just hit court.
I'd been working offshore and uh, it was probably midnight
and, uh, I was heading out to go get a cab people
to the hotel that we had in there in town.
And I'm walking over to a cab
and one of the fellas in the building
and the locals saw me, came running out and grabbed me
and he said, not go in that ca go into that cab.
And I just, I, I was tired.
And I just remember the one he he sent me to
and he went over, he talked to the, the caddy, uh,
when I got in and the guy took me back to the hotel.
Uh, and it turned out that there were a lot of folks
that were closing these caddies and taking people to alleys
and beating the heck out 'em and taking the money
and killing some people in the process of a few cases.
Uh, found out the next morning guy from the same crew had
gotten off and was in the hospital, uh,
after that happened to him that night.
Uh, so I count that as a,
I agree with Aaron.
Um, I believe the doctrine
of Providence has changed my life except for the Bible.
The greatest book that I've ever read is
Providence by John Viper.
I would highly recommend you reading.
It will change your life. It's big. It's 711 pages.
I read it twice 'cause it takes a little bit to absorb.
But if you look at life through the lens
of God's purposeful,
purposeful sovereignty over everything, oh,
the peace and the joy and the comfort
and the lack of fear
and the perfect trust
that will change your life.
I dare you. I dare you read. I dare you.
I have a bunch of true false questions.
Is God purposefully sovereign
over President Trump?
True or false? True.
Is he accomplishing all of his good pleasure
over President Putin?
True. The Taliban
True.
Hamas True.
Your boss,
if you believe in the doctrine, the problem he gives
all the good, all the bad, all the warts.
There is a primary causation and it is God.
Are we morally, responsibly responsible agents? We are.
We're on the hook. God is causing all those things.
Next question.
Does anybody know Romans 8 28
causes all things to work out.
What then is the for my good
in Romans A 28, if all
that happens to me is
Bad, Like
for instance are our baby dies,
my wife gets stricken by cancer,
my mom passes away, I lose my job.
Hmm. How was
that for my good?
Yes sir.
I may be wrong, but I think the passage says all things
work together for good.
That doesn't mean that individual good,
crucified on the cross didn't make for very pleasant,
but it worked together for good.
Because now that person crucified is sitting
and throwing the universe for our,
You can say the same for Paul, but thorn hurt,
but thorn didn't feel good.
But who gave Paul thorn?
If you look at the next verse actually goes back to
what our elder has said.
In my opinion, the answer is in the next verse,
to be conformed to the image of his son.
As bad as it, as bad as the cru fiction was
as bad as filling the blank.
Last question. Why even study this
Experiences a lot of the deeper sense Because
all things work together for good.
But at the end of that is that for his purposes
and if he internally loves us, we're part of his purpose,
I will accomplish all my purpose.
And in the Hebrew that means all my good pleasure.
So if you believe God
and you trust God,
then we can feel confident in that.
Like he's looking out for me.
It might have to be for my eternal good.
'cause you can't say to the martyrs,
well no man, it's for your good.
You can't that it's not good.
Think of all the things that aren't good
burning at the stake that doesn't, that is not good,
but it's for their eternal good or somebody else's or mine.
I mean, who knows? And so
it is that strengthening of faith and love and joy
and trust and rest.
Contentness you become fearless.
It's not cavalier.
It's like Aaron said it. It is. You've got to be kidding.
The dependence that I have on you, it's stunning.
So
I have one question.
I thank you
Mark, uh, has a song for us to close.
See if I can get this work.
Uh, while we stand, we'll, we'll sing this together.
This is my
he,
This is,
Let's pray Again.
Lord, thank you for this reminder tonight
that this is your world, not ours.
You're in control, not us.
Pray as we leave
and as we lay our head down tonight,
we'll remember these things.
What you did today, what you did this week, what you've done
for us our entire lives.
You've been working and doing,
they're paying attention.
So great. Tonight we'll reflect on that.
We'll mark the ways that we see providence in our lives
and let us live in the knowledge that you're in.
Control your work at all.
Thank you all for being here today. Thank.